Jeb Bush has announced theirs Jeb he has
announced that he is going to at least
form an exploratory committee to think
about the possibility of maybe
potentially running for president which
pretty much means he's running for
president here's the note that Jeb
posted on his Facebook page Merry
Christmas and Happy Hanukkah like many
of you our family was blessed with the
opportunity to gather together over the
recent thanksgiving holiday Columba and
I are so proud of the wonderful adults
our children have become and we love
spending time with our three precious
grandchildren we shared good food and
watched a whole lot of football we also
talked about the future of our nation as
a result of these conversations and
thoughtful consideration of the kind of
strong leadership I think America needs
I have decided to actively explore the
possibility of running for president of
the United States in january i plan to
establish a leadership PAC that will
help me facilitate conversations with
citizens across America to discuss the
most critical challenges facing our
exceptional nation packs purpose will be
to support leaders ideas and policies
that will expand opportunity and
prosperity for all Americans in the
coming months I hope to visit with many
of you and have a conversation about
restoring the promise of America best
wishes to you and your families for a
happy holiday season I'll be in touch
soon onward Jeb Bush I don't know if you
know this but his brother was president
two-term president his dad was a
one-term president also the director of
the CIA way back when also a vice
president you know seeing seeing that
photo Jeb is actually holding women down
physically he's not even trying to hide
yeah so he's doing some sort of force
like a Jedi yang to push the women him
down from the glass ceiling yeah so
we've talked about this if I'm not a
dirty way but you could certainly Hitler
for night it could be it could be a
little bit we've talked about the bushes
in the Clintons a lot I'm not a fan of
either of them we left England because
we shouldn't be living under dynasties
and yet these people just keep coming
back and coming back and after we have
Jeb then we'll have Hillary or vice
versa then we'll have Chelsea then we'll
have Malia then we'll have who's after
Malia will get will get Sasha oh that
dog the dog will probably be President
and it all ends with Jaden Smith
becoming our president
it's really just um what do you guys
think just about that concept not even
about Jeb specifically but what do you
think about just this family dynasty
thing even even their mom said we've had
enough bushes in the White House
literally that dirty but uh can't seem
to get away with it but I mean from it
but um yeah I mean it really it's it's
so um incestuous that but almost you
know almost every you know government
politics as honest is an industry yeah
and like any you look at any industry
your father gets you in your parents get
you and your uncle gets you in you know
I have a cousin come you know meet this
guy I mean that's how things happen so
it's more it's more human nature sort of
just like helping the people you know
and your family you think it is no we do
you think it is um and then but we're
not talking about him specifically yet
well we'll get to him specifically in a
second so what do you think about the
big the big picture idea of just these
families that just it's more and more
and more regardless of what I think the
people really want it might be change
right here I see I mean I think that
it's very sad that we've sort of
accepted political nepotism as just the
way the world you know the status quo is
that like you say mm-hmm someone comes
along who has name recognition we just
think oh well I remember someone like
that also had a position of leadership
and therefore yeah the crown should
should be bestowed upon he or she as of
course with Hillary Clinton the thing
that I really worry about with what this
also means is that if these candidates
are boring and and sort of like has
Bin's or I think the toast is done yeah
thank you there's a little bit in there
the host because the bagel is done yeah
someone could get the bagels yeah um I
think that if if if we continue to hear
sort of the same old same old especially
for the generations that are coming up
who are who would be interested in the
political process I think it just
doesn't do anything to excite anybody
because you know it's sort of old news
and I think that's a really dangerous
place to get stuck into when we already
have a hard time reaching voters and
people you know sort maybe I do but you
know you have to have to put I'm sorry
but you have to put some responsibility
on the American public to because we are
we r star searchers this is what we do
we like oh we like famous people yeah we
like people that we know we don't want
to know anything new you don't want to
see the jawline on Jeb Bush I mean
that's that's a movie star right there
right I mean come on lets you have the
judge yeah he does vinheta know I'm a
line I was oh yeah we got to say he
looks more like a soft shadow yeah sort
of like that sort of like a feeling yeah
um so to that point so I agree with both
you I think it's terrible and then I
also agree that it is we're [ __ ]
we like the name recognition there's
this idea of this dynasty family you
think you could say vodka ah there's
yeah you'll get a couple in okay but you
know like the gala we think of places
like the Kennedy compound and what are
the bushes have in Kennebunkport or like
we think of me the brightest these but
really what what could be worse for just
the narrative of the country and just
the discussion and changing things then
Hillary verse Jeb and then we'll get to
the specifics on but just the idea that
nothing we had like a little eight years
of a different guy and then cuz actually
i think is gonna happen here people are
gonna go out we at eight years the other
guy we didn't really like that and now
we're gonna go right well we need the
old guys again right I know but it's
terrible because we are so afraid we say
we want change and yet we don't want to
venture into the unfamiliar yeah you
know in that but that is indicative and
you can look at it almost any area in
our society and it's like that yeah oh
you know environment cars the clothing
people where I mean like everybody how
many people are you looking at this guy
on we were looking at the sky and the
phone hits you know he did somebody who
look so different it's it's like it's
like it things either a freaky or we
want to be part of it you know and it is
that these foreshadowing the story are
they doing in the back that's what was
good
will annotate back to the way we can do
fancy things here well I think that
what's really amazing about this I think
we're totally missing is like the
unbelievably close parallel to back to
the future part two where like 30 years
in the future everybody exactly but I
person who I think who they were in the
aid right yeah and and yet we have no
hoverboard we didn't get wet you know
what we do know yeah we do we do we do
we got out of joke is dated damn good um
we almost have one yeah and you know
that I think it's very sad like we said
before but also boring yeah you know
looks like have something interesting
happen and let's have something that's
that's going to maybe give us a
different look into someone who could
leave the country yeah you know I think
I really think it would behoove us to
all study sociology and CEO history
really does repeat itself and how the
human condition helps to perpetuate it
and in order to get out of this pattern
you gotta take risks and on each
individual has to start taking risks and
in the microcosm of his or her life and
then it can radiate out yeah but why
would anyone want to be President I
don't even think we have to get into the
specifics of Jeb I have a feeling you
don't like Jeb that much but why would
anyone want to be president at this
point when we live in this world where
all we know about hacking and all your
emails can get out and picture I feel
like we just if you want that power at
this point we're like turning a corner
here where every press is going to be at
every turn like we're gonna go into
everybody's gonna be getting impeached
ramallah scandal yeah relentlessly I
really think we're turning a corner into
like bizarro land with why would you
want like this family is so powerful the
Bush family like can't they consolidated
another way that we don't need a guy
that's gonna be President to write or is
it just that power is that look there
you go it's just any good it's ego but I
mean and the only time I've ever felt
this was and I've been a few times but
most recently with my family went to the
to the Reagan Library in Simi Valley and
um you know for all that it is maybe
it's a little bit um you know sort of
one-sided certainly but to go into sort
of experience like what sort of the
optimism I
think that that the projection of the
Reagan legacy is and sort of like the
idea that you can sort of really base
your presidency on being like a
figurehead for for positive feelings
about the country I think that is sort
of like enticing you know if you are
looking for like an ego boost right but
I you know I think that now you know
that was a different time before we had
email we had Twitter we were it was much
easier I think to craft the narrative
than it is right by the way I know that
nothing excites the commenters more than
a positive reference of Reagan so it's a
candy rhys-meyers go to him directly on
there yeah I think that Kathie wrap us
up here well not what I was saying is
that I you know I oops i am at hard and
idealized i think and i like to think
that there is someone who wants to do
good and but in order to do good with in
a corrupt system I honestly don't know
how one goes about yes I completely
agree and I don't you know because in
order to get ahead in the political game
you have to play the political game with
it which is inherently corrupt thus we
get the same families over and over and
things don't change that much